I don't know your life but I know I'm
just I'm telling you how men would see
it
and you can you could say oh men won't
see it that way but we're in a room full
of men I you could ask them how they
would see it okay
after this we will definitely
because let me just uh shout out the
super Chatters man we got two uh big boy
702 he said that he's out we got to him
we got to Brandon Slaughter he says Big
Ups two King Rich's shout out to your
mom Pearl very classy too bad I'm only
five eleven
mom
we'll just see what other options we got
first oh let's rule out here boy we got
to Ryan the eating Warrior again for
another Super Chat he says I was
deployed and my ex-wife made friends
with modern American women and ended up
going to bars and sleeping with a dude
we divorced last month sad she threw our
marriage of five years away one night
over one night but I'm finally moving on
I big up to you man and listen bro like
just keep your head up man like you know
I mean your life is not over and keep
pushing bro and just make yourself happy
bro like thank you for your service and
thank you for your service for the
Americans I'm not American but you know
I was born on Veterans Day so I'm like
really patriotic like carrying the flag
oh okay all right but yeah man like
definitely just let's live your movie
bro and like make the most of your life
and you know what more than likely your
life is gonna be better than hers I'm
just being real real life is more than
likely going to be better than hers in
the long run so you know I mean uh
um all right I've got I got another
question yeah
um why do you think
many men uh in Brackets passport Bros
are leaving the West to find wives in
other countries why do you why do you
think guys a lot of guys like probably
in America and the UK are leaving to go
to find go to other countries to find
women like South America Asia Africa
stuff Caribbean maybe like why do you
think guys are doing that
they might prefer their culture their
cultural how they behave they might
prefer it like I don't know what country
are you from
oh Grenada and Ivory Coast okay would
you what what would you say like the
general culture is like over there like
what are the women like over there
I don't know much well
the crap like traditional traditional
yeah traditional people like like would
you what in what ways like cooking
cleaning kind of just
looking after the home I mean the
Caribbean side it varies you know what I
mean I know it varies but yeah like the
African side from like my friends that
Ivory and I've seen how they're moms and
how they they behave with their husbands
and stuff yeah because there's this
because there's a big movement of
passport Bros and like obviously guys
that are watching you more than likely
heard about it even it was funny because
even one of my good good friends and
he's a guy that does really well with
women and he was talking about it today
and he said he's probably watching right
now and he was like yeah yeah man I'm
possible Bros as well do you understand
and this is a guy that does well he's a
Tyrone certified like do you get what
I'm saying so it's just like I think a
lot of modern women in our side of the
world they're not really understanding
they're not really understanding that
you are losing that like do you get what
I'm saying not you personally but a lot
of a lot of women are losing out what do
you not think about passport Bros
um I think they go over you know as
someone that grew up with nannies from
around the world I just say they're
better overall non-western women they
tend to be more submissive they tend to
be in better shape
and I think for a lot of guys they have
to deal with a bunch of from
women here so they're like you know what
if I can just go find a woman that's
easier she's more submissive and she
wants to be a wife and a mother I'm just
gonna go do that I think that we could
as American women learn from the women
there I'm going to tell you okay and UK
women as well I'm gonna tell you a story
so there is a woman in I think Thailand
or something
she wasn't sleeping with her husband
okay she wasn't she had like postpartum
depression and all this stuff and she
felt so guilty about not sleeping with
her husband that she put an ad for it to
have a girl come in and live with them
and be part of the family and like sleep
sleep with her husband he didn't know
about any of this there were thousands
of women that applied for this ad Okay
thousands
because they would be rent free whatever
like could be she'd be like a part of
the family she just had to sleep with
him whatever what percent of American
women care so much about making their
man happy they would be willing to
swallow their pride and let another
woman live in their home
now I'm not advocating doing that I
think that's a bit odd but the point is
the mindset they care so much about
their husband's happiness that she was
willing to do that
that's the point it's not it's not that
that's a weird dynamic I would you know
but the whole point is that they want to
make their match she wants to make her
man happy so bad that he didn't even ask
her to do that she did that on her own
and I just think that you know that we
can learn something from that we can
look at the countries whatever I wonder
if the man will be that eagle to make
his woman that happy because that's
that's a lot oh he oh he responds he
responded like he um it was funny
because they asked him about him they
interviewed him and he was like yeah I
had no idea but I'm down like you ask
you ask a man can I get a hot young
thing living with me I think a lot are
gonna say yeah it's crazy I mean if the
rules were
was switched I mean like if the man's
working too much he's traveling around
right is he really gonna go and make an
ad for a man to come and never do with
your woman because because I mean
actually because because again men and
women are different it's not the same
but we still have the same needs now
look at throughout history men haven't
been around so this idea that like men
have always been in the house they used
to work in the freaking coal mines what
are you gonna you think your husband's
around they used to work like 12 hour
days on the farm in the fields they
weren't we didn't live in this you know
utopian society where men and women were
just together all the time we thought
about being together all the time but I
I think the idea here is that like like
even even this this mindset here it's
like immediately when we talk about a
man's need we always switch it to the
woman no but this situation is a switch
because both the man and the woman will
need whoa she didn't want it no because
she said about her she didn't need me
I'm not talking about her
is whenever whenever we bring up
whenever we bring up a a story where we
have to talk about the the man it's
always well I gotta flip it we don't
always have me I don't personally but I
did that because I really want to know
if he would go to those extents for her
like that's why I said it yeah but it
doesn't matter
realistic that's that's unrealistic
because who's going to want to probably
have sex more it's gonna be the man so
that even it depends on the woman yeah
but I don't think that's what you were
saying I don't think it was if like he
would go to that extent to fix the
postpartum depression if he would go
yeah for taking care of the children if
he would go to that extent thank you
it's not about just the sex I mean is he
willing to go that far to make you that
happy too like that's why thank you
thank you so much
let's say in general yes um because
again when when the tables are turned
women leave and that's what we see in
the stats and the data is that the
second that the man stops providing
women leave that's one of the number one
indicators of divorce is that when a
woman out earns the husband she gets a
promotion at work she tends to leave in
general when the world women fall for
divorce most of the time where men tend
to stick it out a lot more than women do
it's just it's just the way it is for
him as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible